the government promised that businesses
closed under local lockdowns would get
financial support
and after weeks of wrangling they have
finalized deals with
four regions placed into tier three
restrictions now these
are the deals around a third of the
total you see here is for support with
test and trace the rest
is for businesses south yorkshire will
get 41 million pounds that's the
equivalent of 29 pounds
per person lancashire gets 42 million
pounds 28 pounds
for every citizen liverpool 44 million
pounds around 27 pounds 50
and greater manchester will now receive
82 million pounds
in total that's 29 pounds per head now
we know mayor andy burnham was pushing
for a better deal and that talks
founded on a gap of just 5 million
pounds
so why in the middle of a health
emergency is the government quibbling
over such a relatively tiny figure
the public finances might help explain
coronavirus has sent public borrowing
soaring
here in light blue is last year's
monthly borrowing figures
the dark blue is this year's you can see
how it actually fell
back in the summer as the virus abated
but in september it rose the government
borrowing was 36.1
billion pounds that's 28 billion pounds
more
than last year now 5.9 billion of that
was spent on the furlough
and self-employment support schemes
remember furlough
ends in 10 days and will be replaced
with the cheaper
job support scheme now that spending
helped take public sector net
borrowing to 208 billion pounds
for the past six months alone and it
pushed the national debt
even higher well above 2 trillion pounds
to 103.5
of gdp that's the highest debt ratio
since the 60s but you can see it's
nothing
like as high as it was back at the end
of world war
ii now the chancellor's problem is just
as
he wants to cut the spending the virus
has come
roaring back and calls for more support
not less
will only grow as tier three
restrictions move
south the picture is so uncertain that
he's cancelled
the planned three-year spending review
instead it will cover just one year
and some of those spending commitments
may not last that long
what is certain is that pressure on the
chancellor to spend more
not less on supporting jobs and
businesses will grow
as long as lockdowns are central to
government strategy